Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. It is
available 24 hours a day. And many of you do
call at two, three, four, five in the morning.
Here is a call I got, which actually brings up
a really interesting issue, which is why did it
take this long to find out that George Santos
was lying about just about everything? And
this is an important question. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Aaron. David, this is Aaron Cooper
and a quick thought about Jorge Santos. Yes.
I'm wondering why his opponent, Thomas, did not
uncover all these lies to his campaign. Yep. And
I'm thinking the reason why is because
he ran for governor and lost in the
Democratic primary. And I think after he
just lost limitation, he wasn't going to
interested in winning the New York district.
I just want to get your thoughts. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Listen, this is a very good question.
The George Santos lies. They could have been
uncovered by his opponents opposition research.
They could have been uncovered earlier. We're
talking by investigative journalists, but they
were not. Now, I don't know enough about the
dynamics to blame anyone in particular, but as
a general principle, when you have a guy that
it's not just one lie, it's not, oh, you know,
I used to be a city councilor and I passed an
ordinance and then we researched it and, oh,
you didn't pass that ordinance. This was lied
about employment history, lied about educational
history, lied about ethnic background, religious
background. Call it what you want. Potentially
lied about his mom's death as a result of 911.
Definitely lied about having four employees die
in the Pulse nightclub shooting in 2016. I mean,
lie upon lie about claimed he claimed he owned
property and sold a property, but now says, oh,
I never claim to own property. I can't
give you all the lies that he told.
It is a failure, and maybe it remains to be seen
who failed, that neither investigative journalism
nor opposition research turned up the fact that
this guy was making it all up. And maybe it will
be an instructive example for the future, but I
think that that's a very good point. On today's
bonus show, we are going to start with what
is genuinely a sad story. Friend of the show,
Jamie Raskin, Democratic congressman, who I
think would be a great candidate for president,
has announced that he has cancer and he says it
is serious but treatable and that he expects to
make a full recovery. We're going to talk about
it. We will also talk about an incident in which
a terminally ill patient in a hospital was
vaping cannabis and police were called. And
it escalated very quickly. And in France, they
have passed a law banning single use tableware,
meaning disposable forks and knives at fast
food restaurants. What is the size of that
carbon footprint? How much of a difference
will it make? Is it practical? Do people
like it? Are they furious? Very interesting
decision in France. All of those stories
and more. We're David Sur. Where are these
stories? They're on the bonus show today.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money? Yeah. Everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: That's right. Memberships,
which include access to the bonus show
fund staff salaries, benefits, health care,
connectivity, equipment, legal. We need a lot
of legal folks, etc.. You can sign up at join
Packman dot com. You'll get instant access
to the bonus show. You'll get the commercial
free audio and video streams of the show and
you will be invited to our members only town
halls. All of that and more. Sign up at join
Pacman dot com. I'll see you then. And then we
will be back tomorrow with the final episode of
2026 at the start of 2022. We'll see you back.